you ready hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the whisper
challenge with dumbass dummy and stupid
they can't hear anything that I'm saying
because they're currently jamming out so
they're all really really ugly and not
fun to be around and also not funny have
you seen these guys man there's the
worsen the smelliest I've ever seen so
we're going to get started they're gonna
play I'm gonna read in the fire a tweet
that you guys grow when we chatted it
out
and then they're going to not get it
because their brains just don't work
well enough to do anything right so
we're gonna get this right okay alright
yeah
let's get started
my life so living up okay I like to
smell pickles on a McDonald's hamburger
okay I like to smell pickles on a
McDonald's hamburger yeah yeah yeah
smell yeah you got that I got it right
yeah but you were supposed to pass it on
play what we're supposed to rotate I
wasn't supposed to say it we've done
this before
did you say something about a heart oh I
do not say something about a horse take
off your headphones one more time no oh
take them off Jesus why do I have what
you taught me how to please why right on
line one for Christmas okay okay okay
all right now we're good only one for
you because I'm busy getting popcorn Oh
Ryan I can hear your music
I can hear your music it's so loud good
god okay I'm the only one to bring on
the Christmas ham that wasn't even close
one more time I'm the only one to bring
home the Christmas ham okay okay okay
all right what you got I'm going to go
wash when I get home to see my baby
how could you add like four or five
words from me
just like you have to use your brain
I've been using it the real Albani said
you saw has someone picked up Christmas
and pop you got popcorn
he added Christmas because it was all I
want for Christmas is popcorn okay so
wait you adding it later
yeah he added Christmas after the fact
you had popcorn yeah nothing that I said
that you said sounds like what I said
that still sounded like girls yeah
exactly and then Ryan here I remember
what you said you don't want to see your
baby
unclean I mean that's a fact but it's
nothing to do what we're doing here I
try that's why I don't wash my stomach
when I only eat the placenta and gain
the baby's powers eat the baby's head
off and gained its powers okay look
eat Bonnie's head off and cut out its
bowels
eat Bonnie's head off and cut out its
vowels
bleep bombs head off and cut how long is
this from start to finish it
okay okay all right you get from that
back okay I got eat my towel off I'm the
mouse when I rose the rivers eat the
placenta and gain the babies powers oh
really
I picked up baby to my buddy's head off
and gain its power nice oh that except I
learned something I said
Oh in the finish my son that was the
water yeah yeah
that means boxing nickname you get am at
the mouth oh my god
see God see God okay eat [ __ ] that's it
[ __ ] okay eat dogs okay good no you
said eat Cox said see God and the God
eat [ __ ] you don't eat see
whoa natural thing was Deez Nuts Oh see
it see God Deez Nuts
okay the football game apples are coming
okay oh the purple pants are mine the
purple pants are mine Richard puts the
poopy pastor a bear
the purple bastard a baker
well that wasn't it okay it was the
purple pineapples are coming
oh we said purple goopy
when you think do we look like
permission I guess Jiro bells go to hell
I hope you die okay okay all right
cheese it smells go to hell
one more time wait cheese it smells go
to hell
longer there cut your stick okay Oh No
jeez its smelly jeez it smells like hell
with him all day you got it in one go
yeah I got it geez it's better in hell
with anal all day let's made that I'm
gonna try look at his mouth later if you
can give it another go of your why I
want you to give it another go no I
don't want you to give it another but I
got the real was jingle bells go to hell
I hope you die today
what was the cheese is when jeez we're
gonna get cutting a stick we didn't get
it anywhere you can see where no you all
fail you got go to hell I got go to hell
so do that like furniture my house kind
of I ate a dog there we go
were you like shouting let's blast I you
sorry crack couldn't motorboat me any
day corrected you way
straight motorboat name no man is huh
okay I know you said yeah you're really
okay hey you're really close trick
the cuckoo girl she is a menace
okay do you have the purple pill drink
piss haha oh I know the actual one was
Shrek could motorboat me any day oh I
was close I said straight Motor Co
mayonnaise yeah my head Oh
that's a thing just like seriously know
me your mind is a gutter sir
yeah his mind was distracted my back was
turned
okay so that was the whisper challenge
it went horribly wrong right in there
but hey that's how it normally goes so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you my thighs Ryan and Matt from
kids problems their links are in the
description below
ah whoa whoa and as always we'll see you
in the next video bye bye
my channel then maybe we watch maybe we
will goodbye